[Music]
so
so remember you're not doing
self-defense you're you're coordinating
cultivating yourself a particular way
oh if i have kata jordi
oh really the wrist grabs are about uh
you know a couple of things that are key
i think that you have um
extension not tension
okay so uh when we're doing the
technique it i look relaxed but he's
pushing you can really drive drive drive
drive i'm just relaxed you can stand up
i do the technique
again he's pushing it's really stand up
again
it's a lot of energy he's giving so that
you could see all right so you are
working on that
but the wrist grabs
i find are more about sagittal integrity
of your
center so remember center
is a interdependent relationship between
my extremities
and my tan den
so if my tonsil is
moving in space sagittally
it just
it's not gonna work okay it's gonna move
in front of my four corners or behind my
four corners doesn't work
um
so when you do it
homolaterally
that's what you're doing they're like
hey just worry about one side at a time
fix one side at a time so
foot knee hip
shoulder and then sagittal
integrity of the center there with
extension not tension
when you go to yotadore
they're checking
if you were doing katanta dodi right
you did have the other
corners organized and in that
relationship but now we're checking for
it okay so uh this arm is not not doing
anything it is doing something
so we're here and he takes that away and
he's he's driving that side stays fine
just like it's here it stays fine so i
move
home
i don't want it to not do anything it is
doing something that's why i'm doing
dilted um so that integrity home
here's where i start to see you doing
nothing
so i move
this hand did nothing here
it's doing nothing right here did
nothing
so i'm going to take
this is the
hand
hand okay so i'm going to take
i'm going to take this out you're going
to see that it's actually
doing
something
okay
so it has the strike
then it's
participating
in the kazushi
[Music]
so
the reason is not doing
something is you lost consciousness in
that man
try to
see not a class on
uh
but we'll
make some points
so
i'm whatever i do with this hand it can
only do inward spiral
outward spirals okay so if you pay
attention when i do the first part it's
doing the inward this one's doing the
outward and then they switch rolls
so even here it's not doing nothing
until here
my body my body moves
with these patterns
okay
here it goes again
this hand is going to go this way
not like
this it's going to move this way
around
so we'll take a go to hand out
there here's the pressure that's why i'm
doing ura and so i yield to it
and get out of the way
and i have it continue on its forward
trajectory
[Music]
don't put pressure and try to get the
arm
continue to attack his center by moving
out of the way
and you catch him again on the forward
part
of the circle
all right the other arm
it can only go into the inner spiral
from here from the outside from the yarn
lines on the outside of my torso
can only do the inward spiral coming
from the top going from the bottom we
can do the outer spiral
can't do this
so i combine the two
one i'm going over here
i haven't even touched them yet
it's when this one starts picking up
now it's acting
this just dives in here and waits
to get out of the way
here's where it gets its activity
[Music]
pay attention
to support
this way
that's muscles
[Music]
so as i said at the beginning you're
you're cultivating yourself you're not
learning self-defense okay
um so
if you trained in other arts you would
recognize these movements okay um
so
maybe maybe i have a
palm heel here to to a eye
finger right and uh and then i
keep him from coming in with the palm
hill the disturbance
is
that inward
inward come in boom pop around hit the
back
you're going to see him everywhere he
does the straight punch
you're just coming around here there it
is again up this way this is the hand
coming in right
coming in here
and you actually repeat them over and
over and over in your aikido technique
that is all you do okay
uh
so
my body my four corners my center
relationship
moves these things
via
the ground vectoring whoa
here
here's those stripes
over there oh here i do that
boom
don't try for the arm
shoulder lock it's a stupid technique
from there
home
right here
feel them feel them feel them and just
repeat them
[Music]
be more interested in the patterns than
what you think is a self-defense
technique